timmy i'm here what time is it it's 7 26
a.m
timmy i'm here carl dr burns
i got her
what do you want from me
timmy i'm here why don't you run for me
call darius
hey
hotness
kimmy i'm here reopen the stream on
desktop i need more kitchen paper
open yesterday's stream
[Music]
i'm a voice stream interpreter i may
have heard a crime
on one of the streams the devices pick
up lots of things
just mark this degraded audio and delete
it i am not capable and you know it i
think a woman might need help
how do i find out who she is give me the
device number and the admin code
will you make me one this is the last
favorite hotness
[Music]
closure files come to my office we'll
listen to the recordings together
miss childs i have to know what we're
dealing with we're dealing with what
sounds like a premeditated murder wow
how do i know that because i just told
you
twice now
maybe you've just replaced your real
stresses with this
can we please call the fbi
i understand that you have taken some
mental health leave in the past why is
that in my file
[Music]
you said you had it they did
but now they don't kimmy bedtime lice
is this the only copy i emailed it to
everyone i know this morning
kimmy i'm here
[Music]
[Music]
you